Prince Hassan, how you doing?
>> I'm good, bro. How are you?
>> I'm good, man. I'm good. What What What
message did Paul corrupt or contradict?
>> Everything.
>> Everything. What What message was that?
>> Okay. Do you need to follow the Torah?
Do you need to flood the law? Is there
any reason for you to fle the law?
>> You asking me a question is not
answering the question that I asked you.
So, you can ask me that after.
>> What message did Paul corrupt or
contradict? He told his he told the
Gentiles not to follow the the law
because I I believe it was in Romans
when he says that you only by faith in
Jesus Christ nothing else James said
that okay okay let me not go to James
Jesus said that you need to follow the
law I think in Matthew 5 he says that
>> I got you I got you so in Matthew it has
we we have we can find the message of
Jesus in Matthew we can find the message
of Jesus
>> no I'm just granting a position I I
didn't I didn't give you a position.
>> I just asked a question and then you
went to Matthew. So,
>> no, I'm doing No, I'm No. Okay. He
>> All right. So, you know, let's pause.
Let's start over. I'll give you the
question again. What message did Paul
corrupt or contradict?
>> Okay. Am I doing yes or no?
>> What do you mean an internal critique? I
didn't give you a position. I just asked
you a question.
>> Okay. Okay. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. The
gospels. The gospels. The gospel message
is what is what Paul contradicted and
and corrupted?
>> Yes.
>> Got you. So the gospels are the
authentic gospel of Jesus and Paul
corrupted it.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> Very good. Okay. Good. So Matthew, what
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John wrote.
That's the authentic gospel. That's the
angel. And Paul contradicted it.
>> No. Okay. God lo doesn't know what
internic means. You literally doesn't
know what means because I'm still in a
position that you believe in. You
believe in the gospels. You believe in
the canonization of the of of the New
Testament the 27 books. So I'm still in
that position. I'm telling you Paul
corrupted this message and and are you
okay?
>> Because I'm not Yeah. Because I'm bound
to New Testament.
>> You good? You good?
>> Yeah, I'm good.
>> Okay.
>> No.
>> So what message did Paul corrupt? Did he
corrupt? Did he
>> the message of Jesus Christ? It's very
good. He corrupt message of Jesus
Christ.
>> What was that message? Okay, you choose.
Okay,
>> now he said you he told me to choose.
>> No, where do you want to go?
>> Yeah. Where do you want to go? To the
Quran or
>> I want you to tell me I want you to tell
me what the message of Jesus was and
show it to me.
>> Okay, let's go to the Okay, let's go to
the Gospels. Yeah, he heed Matthew
chapter 5.
>> Okay, so Matthew chapter 5 is the
message of Jesus. Yes.
>> Yes.
>> Awesome. Okay, so let's read out Matthew
chapter 5. Okay, Matthew chapter 5.
>> Was it I believe it was a verse. You're
right. It's verse uh Matthew 5:1 17. It
says, "Do not think that I have come to
abolish the law or the prophets. I have
come not to abolish them, but to fulfill
them. For truly I say to you, until
heaven and earth pass away, not an iota,
not a dot will pass from the law until
all is accomplished." That's what you're
talking about, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Got you. So this is the message of
Jesus in Matthew 5. So I want to read
you something. I want to read you
something in in comparison. Okay.
>> Okay. Can you answer the question or no?
>> I can answer. Just hold on a second. I
want to see something. All right. I just
want to see if you'll be consistent.
Zetas.
>> Okay. Are you going to skip the question
or what?
>> I'm on your I'm on the topic, my
brother.
>> No, you're not. Why did Paul corrupt?
>> Where is
>> Okay. Don't appeal to Don't appeal to
the prophet.
>> One second. Now we know what the are you
going to
>> Now we know what the authentic message
of Jesus is. So I want to make sure that
nobody's out here corrupting it.
>> Are you going okay? Are you going to
apply to the prophet?
>> I'm just going to I'm just going to read
I'm just going to read the Quran really
quick. This what it says in chapter 3:50
talking about Jesus. It says it says
Jesus said, "And I have come confirming
what was before me of the Torah to make
lawful for you some of what was
forbidden to you. And I have come to you
with a sign from your Lord. So fear
Allah and obey me."
>> So according to the Quran, according to
Muhammad's message, Jesus came to change
some of the laws, right? What?
>> It says here that Jesus came to confirm
the Torah and to make lawful some things
that were unlawful. So, he's changing
the law, right?
>> Okay. I'm not familiar with that one.
I'm I'm not familiar. So, what does he
really say?
>> I just read it to you. I'll read it
again. I have come
>> confirming
>> which
>> this is chapter 3 verse 50. If you want
some time to look at it, I'll let you
look at it because really we're about to
see who came and corrupted the message
of Jesus. Who's contradicting the
message of Jesus? Jesus said that not an
iota, not a dot will be passed will pass
from the law until all is accomplished
and that he did not come to abolish the
law but to fulfill it. Muhammad says in
the Quran, Jesus came to to change the
law to abolish some of it. Right?
>> So what is the point? What is the
argument? So the argument is is that
Muhammad in the Quran through the Quran
is contradicting the message of Jesus,
right?
>> No. No, he's not contradicting.
>> I'm confused. Jesus says that he came
not to abolish the law but to fulfill it
and none of the law will be passed away
until heaven and earth passed away and
and things are accomplished. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> The Quran says Jesus came to change some
of the laws. So it's literally
contradicting what Jesus said. No, it
says that it's going to for is going to
make for you something that has been for
forbidden. So what does that mean?
>> So if you make if if you make something
lawful that was unlawful, then you're
changing the law, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So the Quran says Jesus came to change
some of the laws, while Jesus says he
came not to change any of the laws. So
Muhammad's contradicting Jesus.
>> No, he's not contradicting Jesus because
Okay, only a prophet can j something.
Okay, a prophet only can abrogate some
of the things.
>> Oh, there it is.
>> Believe that is a prophet.
>> Oh, so a prophet a prophet can and so as
as long as you I got you. As long as you
believe that hold as long as you believe
that Muhammad is a prophet, it's okay
for him to contradict Jesus.
>> Okay. Can I finish the point there?
Yeah, because okay us we don't believe
that Paul is any prophet like any other
prophets that's why if you read our
sources like
and they says that Christians are the
followers of Jesus Christ until Paul
came we don't believe Paul to be any
other prophet so
>> wait what was what was that first part
>> we don't believe Paul to be any prophet
>> that was the second part what was the
first part you said
>> yeah do you know ali
Kubby.
>> Yeah,
>> I don't care. I don't care about Kubi.
What do you Why are you bringing up
Kubi? What does that have to do with
what we just Okay, I'll tell you.
Because if you appeal to the Quran,
you're doing internal critique. You're
not doing external.
>> Are you Are you good?
>> You good?
>> No, bro. Okay. Okay.
>> I'm just I just want I just want I just
want to make sure you're Wait. So, our
culture be is the is the Quran?
>> No, he's the So, I'm appealing to the
Quran, not a not a commentator, right?
That has nothing to do on what the verse
says. We But we believe in him because
he's the prophet.
>> I don't care what you believe. I care
about what your Quran says.
>> Yes, he did.
>> Okay. So, according to according to your
Quran, did Jesus come to change the law?
>> Yes, he did.
>> According to Jesus's message, I got you.
According to Jesus's message, did he
come to change the law?
>> He said that he's going to fulfill the
law.
>> So, what's the answer? Did he come to
change it or did he come to fulfill it?
>> Okay. What does he mean to fulfill
something?
>> To complete it. To complete it. to
finish it. Did
>> I feel that the law was already
>> Prince Assan? I'm giving you a chance to
have integrity and honesty according to
what we read in Jesus. Did Jesus come to
change the law? Yes or no?
>> He came to fulfill the prophecies.
>> Did he come to change the law? Yes or
no? Is this difficult?
>> No, it doesn't say it changed.
>> So, did he come to change the law? Yes
or no?
>> I'll be No, thank you. No, he did not
change the law.
>> So, when the Quran says that Jesus came
to change the law, the Quran's wrong,
right?
>> No, because no way does he say he he did
not change the law.
>> I'm going to read it to you one more
time and then I'm going to let you be
stupid in the comment section. And I
have come confirming. Matter of fact,
let me put it on the screen so everybody
can see it. If you're on YouTube, guys,
you can see the verse. If you're on
YouTube, here it is. and I have come
confirming what was before me of the
Torah and to make lawful for you some of
what was forbidden. So according to this
verse, it says Jesus literally came to
change some of the laws. Take care of
yourself. Go be an idiot somewhere else.
So we really see who corrupted the
message of Jesus. It wasn't Paul. It was
Momo.
>> Mohamad.
>> Oh yeah. Oh yeah. What's up, bro? You a
Muslim?
>> Yep. What's up?
>> All right, man. What message did Paul
corrupt?
>> What? Did what?
>> What message did Paul corrupt or
contradict?
>> He wrote the entire New Testament.
>> No, he didn't.
>> Well, 80 85 70%, right? He authored
there were 13 books. He only authored
seven confirmed out of the six. What?
>> Unknown.
>> What message did he contradict?
>> That God had a son.
>> Okay. So, what the message was that God
didn't have a son? Yeah. Well, it
contradicts Isaiah, right? Where it says
it states that um
>> Isaiah,
>> the person that's going to be the grand
priest or the supposed son of God is
going to have be born without a father
and father.
>> Wait, the supposed who?
>> The grand priest.
>> Yeah, mach machisel dick. That's what
they call it. You know what machzel dick
is? That's what Why you laughing, bro?
That's what it states in the Bible, bro.
I'm being dead serious. You know what
machelick? Why you laughing? Yo, I'm
going to leave. You know, I'mma leave.
I'mma drop down because of you. This
guy's laughing at his book, bro.
>> Who who who are they talking about?
Who's the grand priest?
>> The Machella dick.
>> Thanks for coming.
>> Why you laughing at your scripture, bro?
>> Man, I I don't know, man. I don't know.
I'm going to try to get somebody that's
a little bit more um a little bit more
there.
>> Yo,
>> what's up? You a Muslim?
>> Yeah, I'm Muslim.
>> All right. What message did Paul
contradict or corrupt?
>> All right. All right. Who made the
books? It was Paul, right?
>> Not all of them.
>> But if Paul and them, they made them.
But they made him after Jesus was
resurrected or whatever y'all be saying,
right? How that how that make sense
though? If they made it after they can't
they literally changed up the whole
Bible.
>> Just be clear, you said you're a Muslim.
>> Yeah.
>> You know that the Quran was compiled
into a book after Muhammad was dead.
>> No, it was not.
>> It was.
>> Um, no. Let me explain. Bro,
>> Muhammad had had had the uh the angel
Gabriel come down to him in a cave.
>> Yeah, but when was it compiled into a
book? When was it compiled into a book?
>> No, it was not. Bro,
>> you don't know that it was compiled into
a book after he died by by uh Abu Bakr
or at least Abu Bakr gave the order to
have it compiled.
>> The the Quran was already made when
Muhammad was alive.
>> But it wasn't compiled into a book.
>> It was.
>> Well, it wasn't. Look, let me show you.
According to your hadith, Abu Bakr gave
the order to Zade Bin Thab to collect
the Quran so that they can pile it
compile it into one book. And Zade Benav
responded by saying, "Why are you
telling me to do something that the
prophet never did?"
>> Which hadith is this though?
>> Sai Bukari 458
one. Let's see. Let's see.
>> The crazy
>> 45.
Give me a second, man. You got to be
patient. All right. You have a lot of
background noise. You like outside.
>> No, not 81. What is it? Hold on. I'm I'm
going to go and mute you, bro, cuz your
your background is way too loud. Uh,
shoot. 4986
then. I think 4986.
Yes, there it is. 4986. All right. Are
you there? Uh, althani, you got to
unmute your mic.
>> All right. So, I'm going to read this
hadith to you. I'm going you you just
stay mute. Stay on mute. I'm going to
read the hadith. Okay. All right. So, it
says narrated Z bin Tab. This is Sukkari
4986. It says Abu Bakr Sadik sent for me
when the people of Yama Yamama had been
killed. Um i.e. the number of the
prophet's companions who fought against
Mus Mus. I went to him and found Umar
bin Katab sitting with him. Abra Bakr
said to me, Umar has come to me and said
casualties were heavy among the Quran.
Those who knew the Quran by heart on the
day of the battle of Yama. And I am
afraid that more heavil casualties may
take place among the Kora on other
battlefields whereby a large part of the
Quran may be lost. Therefore, I suggest
you, Abu Bakr, order that the Quran be
collected. I said to Umar, how can you
do something which Allah's apostle did
not do? Umar said, by Allah, that is a
good project. Umar kept on urging me to
accept his proposal till Allah opened my
chest for it and I began to realize the
good and the idea which Umar had
realized and so on and so forth. It
continues but I just wanted to show you
that. So do you see how they could had
the Quran compiled in a book and
Muhammad never did that? They did this
after Muhammad was dead.
>> All right. All right. Answer answer my
question. Do you think Jesus is God?
>> You think that you're going to is Jesus
God your way out of this?
>> No. No. I'm just asking you. Do you
think Jesus is God?
>> I know you're just asking.
>> It's just a question.
>> You're trying to Is Jesus God your way
out of this one? Huh?
>> I'm not. I'm just I'm just asking you a
question. Do you think Jesus is God? Who
is your God?
>> Your question is to escape. It's called
what we It's what we call the Muslim
shuffle. It's when you hit us with some
type of distraction or deflection to get
out of the pot. But unfortunately, I'm a
good chef and I never let my food jump
out the pot. You're not going to is
Jesus good your way out of this, bro.
Not going to happen. You said that the
New Testament was made was written after
Jesus resurrected after he left the
earth. So how can it be true when it
wasn't collected into a book or made
into this book in his lifetime while he
was here on earth? Well, that objection
goes back to you. How can you say that
the Quran that you have is true and
trustworthy when it wasn't compiled into
a book until after Muhammad died?
Muhammad never did this. So, how can you
say that the Quran you have is
trustworthy and true and not fabricated
by Abu Bakr and Umar and Uman and Zade
Bin Tabat? You got to come back to the
screen, bro, cuz I can't hear you if
you're off the screen. Ain't no jumping
out the pot here, man.
>> Yo, you hear me?
>> Yeah, I can hear you now. Did you hear
everything I said? You got to stay on
the Tik Tok app for me to hear you, bro.
All right, I'm going just go ahead and
let this one go. Take care, ma'am. Watch
your head on the way out. Oh, logic,
logic, logic.
>> You're a Muslim.
>> Me? Alhamdulillah.
>> All right. What message did Paul I would
give you the salam, but you know, you
will not give me the back. So, I would
not give you that.
>> Why wouldn't I give it back to you? My
Lord tells me to greet even my enemies
or people that disagree with me.
>> Which one? Which one? Jesus the father,
the son, the holy spirit.
>> Jesus.
>> But you you know what's what's the funny
thing? Logic.
>> Why don't you give me the peace greeting
so I can give it back to you?
>> No, no, no. Forget about that. But you
know what's the funny thing? Forget
about that. Forget about that.
>> No, no. I I mean, what's the funny
thing?
>> No. Give me Give me the peace greeting.
>> I've been watching you for many times.
You're
>> Thank you, man. I appreciate it,
brother. Give me the peace greeting so
we can continue.
>> Just the respect. If if we have
>> Yes. So, for respect to be polite, give
me the peace greeting, bro.
>> What? What's the peace greet?
>> You know what the peace greeting is? How
you greet your your your Muslim
brothers.
>> So, you have to give me first so I can
give you back.
>> Why do I have to give it to you first?
You came on my live.
>> No, but if you want to uh then give me,
I give you back. If you don't Why can't
Why can't you give it to me first?
>> Because you do not believe what I
believe.
>> What What does that have to do with you
being polite and giving me a nice peace
greeting?
>> Oh, you are good. You are good. I I I I
first first I thought you know you are
but forget about it. You But let me ask
you one question. Listen listen my
English is not perfect. So if you want
to ask me question you have to speak you
know you have to speak slowly not fast.
>> All right. What what message did Paul
corrupt or contradict?
>> The forget about the power. The whole
pipel is corrupt.
>> Okay. What message?
>> Even even your priest your priest says
that not you the one that came before
you. There's a one there's a one thing
in Islam that there was a
>> How you doing? Are you a Muslim?
>> Hello my brother. Yes, I'm I'm Muslim.
>> Do I pronounce your name Aladin or is it
Aladdin?
>> Aladdin. That's fine.
>> Okay.
>> But I You got to also talk about the my
my last name though, which which is the
matrix. You know, I live in a matrix.
>> Okay. I like that. I like that. Are you
a Sunni Muslim, Shia Muslim, Quran only?
Ahmedi?
>> I am Sunni Muslim.
>> Sunni. Okay.
>> I am well Quran is the only authority.
So I have to give it Quran first.
>> Okay, I got you. So um do you are you of
the opinion that Paul corrupted the
message? So, you know, I'm not going to
blame everything on Paul, okay? But we
do know that uh 300 300 years later
after Jesus passed away, right? The
council of Nika
>> kind of decided, you know, what is true
Christianity and whatnot and what really
happened during that time because it was
Roman Empire we are dealing with. I'm
not talking about the council of Nika
and all those misconceptions because
that's not true. I'm asking about Paul
specifically. Do you believe that Paul
corrupted the message?
>> So I don't know much about Christianity
to affirm you or say anything like that.
I I I don't have that kind of knowledge
as far as like the goes.
>> Okay. So if that's the case, then I
would suggest that you don't bring up
something like the Council of Nika and
saying that that's what established
Christianity if you don't really know
what Christianity was.
>> I Well, I know as far as like the
history goes, what I know is that they
burn all the other books.
>> That's not what happened in the Council
of Nia, bro.
>> So they kind of decided, right? No.
>> What happened?
>> None of that happened. None of that
happened at all. So that's why I'm
saying you shouldn't bring up the
council of Nika until you like I guess
like do more reading. Okay.
>> When did the whole triune thing happen?
>> That that happened in Genesis.
>> Was it is the Genesis the Old Testament
or the New Testament?
>> That's the Old Testament is the very
first book of the Torah.
>> So it literally talks about the triune
God.
>> Yes.
>> Do you have any particular scripture
that shows that? Yeah, we have many
scriptures that show it, you know. So,
we we don't take one scripture just by
itself, but we look at all the
scriptures
>> together as a whole and what it
demonstrates. So, you have all
throughout Genesis, it talks about God
in the plural. You have God in chapter
one saying, "Let us make man in our
image, in our likeness."
>> So, God speaks to of himself in the
plural and there is no plural. Even
Quran, even Quran talks about God in in
a plural sense though. But he is still
he is still one though.
>> He is one. So God is one God who exists
as a plurality of persons. Now you this
will actually kind of be a problem for
you in the Quran cuz when Allah is
speaking of himself in the plural, how
do you know that it's not a plurality of
persons? So this is where you you know
uh cuz see fact of the matter is let me
just explain this whole thing right we
humans are very much limited into third
dimension right when do God talks about
when he was talking through plurality
right he he exceeds the limitation of
time and space okay he ex he he can
exist everywhere and anywhere at the
same time that's my point So God, as far
as my knowledge goes, even though this
is has nothing to do with Islam, Muslim
and whatnot, I personally know or
believe as far as my research goes, that
God exists at the 10th dimension.
>> Okay. So do you do you believe just to
make sure that we're kind of having a
focused conversation, do you believe
that the previous scriptures before the
Quran uh were corrupted or do you
believe they're intact and preserved? We
Muslims believe it was partly corrupted.
Partly part of it.
>> You think it's partly corrupted? Who do
you think corrupted it?
>> Over time, it happens over it's just it
just you know uh the Old Testament came
and uh came about 1500 BC, right? 1500
years later Jesus came. So we are
talking about 1500 years.
>> What does that have to do with
corruption? The Quran came 600 years
after Jesus. Does this mean that like is
the Quran corrupted?
>> No. The Quran came 1400 years ago
though, right?
>> Right. So,
>> so that is the only book God said he
he's going to he's going to preserve.
>> Can you show Can you show me that?
>> It's it's been shown through
mathematics.
>> No. Can you show me that? Can you show
me that in the Quran that Allah says
that the Quran is the only book he's
going to preserve?
>> You know, mathematics is the language of
the universe, right? So, there are many
instances in Quran which is literally
>> I don't want to be rude. I don't want to
be rude to you. I think that uh this
isn't this this isn't the conversation
you and I can have. I'm gonna go ahead
and move on. Okay.
>> All right. Take care.